name your price if you have to chess box
um $10 million do you prefer to play
chess on a computer over the board or on
your phone I rarely play on my phone I I
would say I prefer to play on the
computer in your entire career have you
ever had a day where you went I think
this guy might be as good as me in
chess
no uh well I mean not not not you know
since not the last 10 years for sure
okay has it ever
been this guy might be kind of close to
me if I have a bad day yeah uh I would
say Fabia to his best was um very close
in In classical for sure my other
question was going to be who do you
think is the second best chess player in
the world so I suppose yeah I think
Fabian corana is the is the second
second best player